i mean and some of the things that he
says is so distorted and out of tune
with reality i had to call him on that
okay i have a question what if dr fauci
is not telling us the truth
why should we have endless trust in a
public health establishment that has
failed us six ways from sunday
as we've been talking about the public
health establishment has completely
failed on every messaging level with
regard
to the vaccination the reality is you
didn't really have to master this thing
mis-message this thing very hard
you know how i know because everybody
who's old got the vaccine
because they saw that if they didn't get
it there was a good shot they were going
to die
and so they were like okay i'm getting
the vaccine this is a really easy sell
and people take a look at the risk
factors and then they determine for
themselves what is going on
but the biden administration because
they wanted us to be all done
by now and they really don't care about
whether individual human beings choose
one way
or the other they have decided that the
real reason that there is vaccine
hesitancy is of course
because of right-wing misinformation and
because social media refused to quash
this right-wing misinformation this is
part of a broader media narrative that
has been out there for a while in which
the media push
social media to quash all dissenting
information from a bunch of different
sources right this is why npr had an
article earlier this week
openly saying that daily wire should
basically lose its traffic because daily
wear is conservative not because we lie
not because we're anti-vaccines not
because of any of that just because they
don't like us
so normally you might expect the media
right you know a first amendment outfit
you might expect them to say to the bite
administration guys
why is it your job to tell social media
what can and cannot be
distributed on social media but i mean
this is just
excellent evidence that our media are
just the the praetorian guard for the
democratic party
they now just mirror whatever is the
narrative that the white house wishes to
purvey
so if the white house says it's social
media's fault instead of the media going
wait
the social media is a platform why is
the government trying to pressure
platforms to remove information instead
the media is like
yeah social media why don't you remove
misinformation
here was nbc nightly news just doing the
same thing the white house would do
except indirectly
how does social media influence people's
relationship with facts so in our
research you know across different
countries including the united states
what we find is that when people receive
most of their
information about covert 19 and
vaccination from social media
they're more likely to be misinformed
and they're less likely
to get vaccinated versus when they get
their information from official
sources like the wh or the cdc
so we actually can identify a clear link
between getting your information from
social media
and having a greater amount of
misconceptions about this issue
which in turn is linked to lower
willingness to get vaccinated
don't you see that you should be getting
all your information only from official
sources
does this sound a little bit fascistic
to you the only places you should be
able to get information
about covet maybe for anything is the
who and the cdc
except for how the wh and cdc have
flipped 1 000 ways since the beginning
of this pandemic
and if you'd listened to the who at the
very beginning you wouldn't have masked
up or the cdc you wouldn't mess
up and if you listened to the who up
through about five minutes ago
the covett lab league theory was totally
crazy and if you listen to the who at
the very beginning of this pandemic it
wasn't even an airborne virus covered
except for that you know it's really
only government only trusts the
government is a hell of a take from the
press
from the press these people who are like
i'm gonna hold power
to to account we're gonna we're gonna
force accountability from the powerful
make life uncomfortable for the
comfortable except
if they're of my political party in
which case i will say they ought to be
the only informational source from which
you derive information that was nbc
nightly news not the white house
amazing you see the same thing from a
columnist named will arimus over at the
washington post
has a piece titled facebook and
youtube's vaccine misinformation problem
is simpler than it seems his analysis
in the end is not that youtube and
facebook ought to just ban information
outright instead he says they should
basically just shadowban
it much better much better they should
just change all of their algorithms so
the only things you can see are the
things that joe biden
wants you to see which of course is a
restriction on free determination of
information
obviously that that's that's what it is
now again when we get to misinformation
from the federal government
let me just point out at this point that
dr anthony fauci is misleading you right
now
okay so dr anthony fauci oversaw
the nia id which is part of the nih nih
did give grants to a place called eco
health alliance equal health alliance
did give those grants to the wuhan
institute of virology
the huan institute of horology performed
what is in effect gain of function
research on covet 19
or at least on on it appears on covet 19
right we don't know if it was from the
wet market
now china's saying no it is it is highly
unlikely that this was produced anywhere
but the wuhan institute of virology
and since kova 19 does not exist in bats
but now it does exist in humans it is
highly likely that it was
created through gain of function
research now that doesn't mean that the
eco health alliance grant was
specifically used to produce coven 19
it does mean that the equal health
alliance grant from the nih was used for
gain of function research in wuhan
now the slippery way out of this little
conundrum for fauci and the nih
is to claim that technically they
weren't funding gain and function
research
technically the kind of research they
were funding was just about
making animal viruses transmissible in
humans not about making it more deadly
in humans
that's a very technical distinction that
really makes no difference for purposes
of the conversation
okay the reality is that dr fauci has
been a wide
a wide and deep supporter of gain of
function research for years and years
and years because he likes the idea
that that gain of function research
helps us fight future viruses
there's a case to be made for gain and
function research by the way there is no
case to be made that gain of function
research being done under the authority
of a totalitarian regime with no
incentive
for actual health structures ought to be
funded by the united states you want to
say
fun gain of function research at harvard
go for it man you want to say
fun gain of function research in china
at the wuhan institute of virology
that's nuts okay now fouchu was called
on the carpet by rand paul for this
and fauci basically we're not funding
gain of function research we had nothing
to do with cover 19. you don't know have
you had anything to do with coven 19.
i don't know whether you had anything to
do with cover 19. what is pretty clear
is that you were not cutting off funding
for the wuhan institute of horology
which was performing
exactly the kind of research that would
have led to a lab leak if indeed this
was a lab leak
nonetheless here is anthony fauci
slamming rand paul for quote-unquote
slanderous commentary
i don't take any great pleasure ari in
in clashing with the senator i have
a great deal of respect for the
institution of the senate of the united
states
but he was completely out of line he
totally distorted
reality and he made some inflammatory
and i believe slanderous remarks
about lying under oath which is
completely nonsense
i mean in some of the things that he
says is so distorted and out of tune
with reality i had to call him on that i
didn't enjoy it
but i had to do that because he was
completely out of line
totally inappropriate now you may notice
that
dr fauci never actually explains what
rand paul said that was overtly false he
may not like the implications
that rand paul is drawing he may rely on
this distinction between technical gain
of function research and
gain and function research on like a
broad philosophical level
but nothing that rand paul said was
actually wrong here the nih director
does the same thing again remember these
are your governmental sources you trust
them
well we're told these are the only
people you should trust here's the nih
director
defending fauci i'm very concerned when
i see
probably the most highly respected
infectious disease doctor
on the planet being treated this way
having these accusations without any
basis thrown at him
stirring up all kinds of nasty
outreaches to him that
require him now to have 24 7 security
detail
to protect him and his family what has
happened to us
that somebody who's trying to help the
public by telling them the truth
is turned into this kind of demonized
character for political purposes
it is unacceptable okay i have a
question what if dr fauci is not telling
us the truth
that's the question here's rand paul
asking precisely that question yesterday
well i think it's important to know that
dr falchi has a self-interest
in obscuring any relationship or
responsibility for anything done in the
wound lab
without question the evidence we
presented in committee yesterday
shows that the nih was funding research
in wuhan we showed the exact
numerical uh series of numbers that goes
with the grant number so yes they were
funding the wuhan lab but you have to
realize that dr fauci is not
disinterested
if this virus came from the lab and it
becomes clear that he was funding
dangerous research
moral culpability responsibility
attaches to him and he does not want
that
okay but the bottom line is this this
really isn't about voucher generally
it's about
why should we have endless trust in a
public health establishment that has
failed us six ways from sunday
it is private industry developing the
vaccines that did not fail us the public
health experts failed us it was bad
information at every turn
in some cases they overtly lied to us
but the bite administration idea is that
only those people ought to be listened
to and we have to
just submit our own personal judgment to
the
to the tender mercies of these exact
people
the answer for most americans is no and
that means it's time to get read
it's time to get back we now the
vaccines it's time to get back to
something approaching regular life
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe